if there's one thing that you can  improve about Chia what would it be  watch this video or anything like that  one of our biggest issues she doesn't  realize the way she says things  sometimes like a [ __ ]  [Laughter]  her approach isn't always the greatest  her delivery isn't the greatest so I'm  like hey man look uh sometimes the way  you talk to me uh so I feel a little  it's a little condescending you feel me  and I'm not a stupid boy I'm a grown ass  man I just don't talk to me like I'm  dumb right  or like sending voice memos back and  forth Tim was telling me something and  in the background in here she'll go no  we're not moving to Vegas bar yeah bro  I'm like I don't want to buy a house  from Ant dog I'm good